[Musique]
les paysages légendaire de l'époque des
rois gaélique sont intactes tout aussi
beau d'un côté comme de l'autre
qu'on soit dans l'union européenne au
sud ou dans le royaume uni au nord ici
les moutons peuvent brouter de part et
d'autre d'une frontière invisible tout
en restant dans leurs pâturages les
habitants de la région ont tué aussi
appris à profiter du meilleur des deux
mondes la station service et le magasin
général de demon fitzpatrick sont situés
littéralement à cheval sur la frontière
le patron en a fait sa marque de
commerce les tarifs sont affichés en
euros et en livres sterling la livre
sterling a perdu de sa valeur depuis le
vote favorable aux briques site
iman fait patrick craint que cette chute
ne s'aggrave
une fois le divorce consommé il
souhaiterait rester en europe donc en
irlande
côté sud mais cela le forcerait à
refaire tous ces chemins d'accès ou
commerce allait se demande bien qui va
payer pour tous a de meilleur les
résidants du coin comme stephen moore
ont encore du mal à comprendre ce qui
leur arrive
[Musique]
les clients commerciaux des mines
fitzpatrick sont aussi très inquiets ce
sont en grande partie des agriculteurs
qui habitent des deux côtés de la
frontière
notre vendeur de carburant franchi
plusieurs fois par jour la frontière
entre le sud et le nord pour effectuer
ses livraisons
tant que les deux irlande étaient
membres du marché commun européen soit
depuis 1973
on n'y voyait aucun problème mais plus
maintenant
mon lait est transformé au sud de dit il
mais les produits repartent la plupart
du temps vers le nord pour être vendus
est né yo ké sa ferme produit du lait et
du boeuf avec l'aide des subventions de
l'union européenne
que va-t-il se passer au lendemain du
breakbeat d'entraîneur n'en sais rien
un agriculteur pense que la création
d'une nouvelle frontière va
nécessairement entraîner de nouvelles
taxes et des tracas bureaucratique et
mon envie rarissime volts les
agriculteurs de la république d'irlande
exporte l'équivalent de six milliards de
dollars de marchandises par année au
royaume uni dans le sens inverse les
transactions agricoles sont presque
aussi élevé les agriculteurs irlandais
du nord et du sud réclame donc d'être
exempté des conséquences du breakbeat
s'il ya des nouvelles tâches
la moitié des producteurs de champignons
vont fermer leurs portes
assure ce jeune fermier mais la pire
crainte dit il c'est que si les murs
viennent
il revient aussi dans nos têtes le long
de cette frontière discrète
il y a aussi des gens qui appuient le
break site ce sont en grande partie des
unionistes britannique convaincu le
broker a grandi ici et combattu pour
l'armée de lutter pendant trente ans il
se dit convaincu que le brésil puisse
faire sans risque de raviver les plaies
entre protestants et catholiques mais il
avoue que les cicatrices sont encore
fragiles à camion- rédac un des shows
freins les lieux communauté ont des
relations très cordiales en surface d'y
awad
mais elle reste fondamentalement dit
lisez encore aujourd'hui des deux ici
dans le sud de l'irlande du nord à la
campagne la frontière suit les méandres
de la rivière
c'est une sorte de frontière naturelle
que les erreurs des ronds tendance
d'ailleurs a oublié de part et d'autre
ce qui est radicalement différent de ce
qui se passe en ville à belfast
belfast porte encore les cicatrices de
la guerre de trente ans qui a fait des
milliers de morts les dizaines de
milliers de blessés
entre 1969 et 1998 ce qui guide les
touristes près du mur qui sépare encore
aujourd'hui les quartiers catholiques et
protestants sont souvent d'anciens
combattants comme jake dowell en
république est catholique qui a lutté
dans les rangs de l'ira
il fait partie de ceux qui réclament une
réunification des deux irlande pour
qu'est celle du nord demeure elle aussi
au sein de l'union européenne
les touristes ont aussi droit à une
brève rencontre entre deux anciens
ennemis
c'est un ex combattants des forces de
défense de luxe terre qui les entraînent
de l'autre côté du mur
chez les unionistes du célèbre quartier
championne théâtre de nombreux attentats
à la bombe
ici les opinions largement favorable au
breakbeat sont tranchées ici on est plus
britannique que les britanniques dit il
mais ce sont les plus vieux qui jettent
de l'huile sur le feu nous les jeunes on
pense au futur
cet homme avoue lui qu'il aimerait bien
assister au retour des gardes frontières
pour tenir les gens de l'ira à distance
dit il depuis les accords du vendredi
saint de 1998 qui ont mis fin à la
guerre
plusieurs projets de destruction du mur
de belfast ont été élaborés mais aucun
gouvernement n'a encore osé prendre ce
risque
le mur sépare encore les deux groupes y
compris dans les parcs
cette jeune mère protestante dit qu'elle
aime bien venir dans la section
catholique du parc qu'elle trouve plus
calme le matin
mais quand on lui demande si on pourrait
se passer aujourd'hui de ce mur l is it
il y a encore des gens qui se comportent
d'une manière anti sociale dit elle il
vaut mieux garder le mur pour l'instant
mais laissez les nombreux passages
ouverts le j 20 ans après la signature
des accords de paix les voies de
communication entre les deux communautés
d'irlande du nord sont encore lourdement
obstrué
dans le contexte actuel du brésil
elle risque bien de le rester
[Musique]